Beauty brands are talking a
lot more about sustainability
and the environment and it makes sense
climate change is a huge problem and most
of us don't want to make things worse
well maybe not him
but beauty marketing is full of false
promises and meaningless buzzwords
what's actually better for the
environment and what is feel-good fluff?
well most of it is fluff
I'm Michelle chem PhD cosmetic
chemist and marketing connoisseur
I'm here with Jen another cosmetic chemist
and science communicator who
specialises in sustainability
we're going to break down some
of the most common myths that
brands use to pretend they're greener
than they are so you can see through
the marketing more easily and make
informed decisions about what to buy
but it's not all doom and gloom we will
also go through things we can do to
actually be more sustainable
so stick around till the end
let's start with the idea that natural
ingredients are better for the environment
than synthetic ones when you finish using
them and they drift off into the environment
this myth shows up a lot with sunscreens
some places are banning chemical sunscreens
because of the idea that they harm coral
reefs but this isn't based on good
evidence I've talked about it before
instead these places are promoting mineral
sunscreens mostly with zinc oxide based
on on this assumption that it is natural and
therefore won't harm coral or any other wildlife
this is not true
when zinc oxide sunscreen gets washed off your
body it doesn't necessarily end up someplace
that naturally has zinc oxide and even if it does
it can raise the concentration there compared to
before and how harmful something is depends on how
much there is so extra zinc oxide can be a problem
there are actually a lot of studies showing that
zinc oxide is toxic to coral
and other aquatic organisms
for example these data tables come from a 2022
National Academies report on the
environmental impacts of sunscreen
each of these rows is an example of a harmful
effect that zinc oxide has been found to have
there's also this diagram that compares the
toxicity of different chemical and physical
sunscreen ingredients each black dot is an
amount that caused a toxic effect in a study
the lower a dot is on this graph the less
you need of that ingredient to have the
harmful effect - in other words
the more potently harmful it is
you can see that both zinc oxide and titanium
dioxide (the other "natural" sunscreen) can
start causing harm at lower concentrations
than some "unnatural" chemical sunscreens
as the report says these two categories of
UV filters completely overlap
with respect to acute toxicity
and this is still the case
with non-nano zinc oxide
nano refers to smaller particles that tend to
be used in sunscreens because
they protect against UV better
and they look a bit less clown-like
in a lot of sunscreen marketing you'll see this
idea that if you use larger non-nano particles it
will be completely safe but zinc oxide dissolves
in water which means larger particles get smaller
like and subscribe for more
mind-blowing facts like these
plus those dissolved zinc ions can also be harmful
zinc is a micronutrient that living organisms need
but it is also a heavy metal -
it's toxic if there's too much
that's why if you look up the safety data sheet
for zinc oxide you'll see this
symbol featuring a dead fish
it's surrounded by warnings about
how it's "very toxic to aquatic life"
zinc oxide even when in non-nano form has
been recognised as potentially
toxic for a really long time
neither chemical nor physical sunscreen
seems to be a big issue for coral reefs
based on the relevant evidence so far the
amounts near reefs are too low to be having
that much of an impact especially in light
of other stressors like rising temperatures
research is still ongoing also
for other aquatic organisms
but it's pretty clear that zinc oxide
isn't a completely safe alternative and
this goes for pretty much any natural ingredient
just because it's natural doesn't
mean it's safe which you hopefully
already know because nature
is always trying to kill us
also the zinc oxide and titanium dioxide in
sunscreens isn't really natural most of the time
it's usually man-made
that's because if you just take them from nature
they're often contaminated with very
natural toxic heavy metals like lead
this is also the reason why natural iron
oxides which are the skin colored pigments
in foundation aren't allowed in cosmetics
in the US they have to be synthetic
when we talk about the environmental
impacts of different ingredients in
our products we usually focus on where the
ingredients go after we finish using them
this is going to be a recurring theme
what we can see and control is usually
what we think about where the
product goes after we've used
it (we can see it going down the drain)
and what we do with the empty packaging
but this is only one part of
environmental impact there's also
getting those ingredients in the first
place and a lot of people assume that
natural ingredients are more environmentally
friendly to produce than synthetic ones
again this is not true and this production part
is a really big factor when it comes
to the overall environmental impact
the more holistic way of thinking about impact
is to look at the whole life cycle of the product
this is the life cycle most of the time we focus
on this part which is disposal and
recycling also called end of life
but there's a lot that happens before the product
actually gets to you and all of
these have environmental impacts
the raw materials get processed and turned
into ingredients which then
get turned into your product
the same steps happen to make the packaging
your product then gets shipped a bunch of times
there's also a bunch of
shipping in that first part
then it ends up at your house
you use it which is another
big part of the impact for example with water use
and THEN there's the disposal and recycling
we've already talked about the disposal of
ingredients and how natural isn't always better
but natural also isn't automatically
better when it comes to production
when we hear natural it kind of sounds like
[ASMR voice] someone wanders through a
forest and picks leaves off trees and
mashes them to make your products
while birds chirp and deer dance
it just SOUNDS more sustainable
but that is pretty far from reality
there are lots of natural ingredients that
have huge environmental costs to produce
for example essential oils it can take
hundreds to thousands of kilograms of
plant material to get a single kilogram of
essential oil and many essential oils are
mostly sourced from plants growing in the wild
or at least the wild versions are more valuable
one example that Jen's talked
about before is Indian sandalwood
Jen: Sandalwood is the most economically
important tree globally the value hinges
on aromatic chemical composition
namely high santalol content
santalol content is
concentrated as trees get older
harvesting generally happens
when the trees are 30 years old
this coupled with growing demand plus widespread
fungal infection has driven
the species to endangerment
adulteration smuggling and illicit
trade remain major challenges
Michelle: another example is licorice
extract in skincare it's usually wild
harvested licorice that's used because it has
a higher concentration of the active components
Jen: wild licorice has been uncontrollably
over harvested to the point that there is
now more licorice being sold in the
market than there is being produced
licorice helps soils with sand management and
therefore over exploitation of wild licorice
in the sandy regions it typically grows
directly contributes to desertification
Michelle: for both sandalwood and
licorice the obvious solution is
to limit wild harvesting which is
harder than it sounds and switch to
farmed versions which is a bit less
natural and usually lower quality
there's been efforts to increase
the quality of the farmed versions
but that is also harder than it sounds
and even though in these cases farming
is more sustainable than wild harvesting
it is still not great for the environment
Jen: agriculture has a huge
impact on the environment
according to the 2019 IPBES report
agricultural expansion into intact
ecosystems was the greatest
threat to biodiversity loss
agriculture is also a significant
contributor to greenhouse gas emissions
Michelle: and we don't just
farm cosmetic ingredients
the land and resources could've
been used to produce food instead
Jen: food security is a really big
issue right now we have an immense
global challenge of figuring out how
to feed our growing population with
the limited resources we have
while also reducing our impacts
from my perspective it's hugely
problematic to divert agrispace
away from food towards production of things
like cosmetics or aroma chemicals especially
if there's a less impactful way
of production already available
Michelle: and these less impactful ways
of production can be natural or synthetic
Jen: ultimately it's complex and it depends
many natural materials in cosmetics
are byproducts of food agriculture or
even biodiesel production albeit this in
itself is problematic for similar reasons
some essential oils are produced
via byproducts and can be considered
as upcycled for these the continued
use of natural materials makes sense
Michelle: and a lot of the time ingredients
made from byproducts are also cheaper
this links to another really annoying
marketing trope a lot of clean natural
brands like to brag about how precious and
rare their ingredients are how many rose
petals are in each bottle how long it took to
grow and they shame other ingredients which are
usually synthetic for being "cheap" and then at
the same time they claim to be more sustainable
this makes zero sense if more resources went into
making a product that is not more sustainable
"cheaper" ingredients that are made from
salvaged waste materials are usually a more
sustainable option even though there
is this sort of snobbery against them
turning waste into something useful and valuable
is a good thing from an environmental perspective
and on this theme of making the most out
of limited resources here is the next myth
organically farmed ingredients are more
environmentally friendly than
conventionally farmed ones
most people think "organic" means more
environmentally friendly because that is what
organic farming organisations say that their goal
is it's in all four of their founding principles
but if you look at the actual rules that
farmers need to follow to be "certified
organic" you'll see that they aren't
actually based on scientific evidence
it's mostly just based on this idea of naturalness
"in general synthetic substances [like pesticides
and fertilizers] are prohibited [...]
and non-synthetic substances are allowed"
but like we've discussed natural isn't necessarily
better for the environment and
this applies to pesticides too
more and more studies have found that organic
farming can actually end up with greater
environmental impacts in a lot of areas
this 2017 meta-analysis compared a bunch
of studies looking at the environmental
impacts of conventional versus organic farming
they looked at producing 90 different foods
the higher a dot is on this graph the worse
organic farming is compared
to conventional farming
first off you can see that a lot of it
depends on the type of food the different
colored dots represent different categories
of food and they're at different heights
there is also a lot of variation for the
specific farms in different countries
for a lot of the data sets
there's a really long line
which means that there is a huge range involved
so it isn't like organic is always better
or conventional is always better but there
are some categories of environmental
impact where organic is generally worse
and since then there's been more analyses where
scientists have started taking land use into
account when looking at the greenhouse
gas impact which this analysis didn't do
organic farming tends to be less efficient
more land is needed to produce the same amount
of a crop and if you're using that land for
farming you will generally need to clear trees
having less trees means that you
have less carbon dioxide being
absorbed so there is essentially
going to be an opportunity cost
and if you factor that greater land use in it
turns out that organic farming usually
produces a lot more greenhouse gases
one analysis found that in Sweden organic
peas would have a 50% greater greenhouse gas
impact than conventionally farmed peas for
winter wheat the difference was 70 percent
Jen: in order to meet our growing
demand in light of the environmental
limitations and impacts associated
with agriculture we need to figure
out how to produce more ingredients
with the same or even less impact
despite that there is a market push to tell
us that organic is sustainable there are some
serious limitations of organic agriculture
especially pertaining to its efficiency
this isn't to say that organic agriculture
is unsustainable full stop in some regions
it may make sense in the same way that in
other regions conventional agriculture or
even genetic engineering may be the better option
ultimately there are no panaceas when it
comes to sustainability in agriculture
Michelle: whether organic or conventional methods
are better changes a lot depending on the context
and what impact you're looking at not even
just with the specific crops and environmental
impacts but also things like pesticide
exposure for farmers and consumer prices
even if we look at biodiversity which is one of
the more widely accepted advantages of organic
farming it turns out that if you take that extra
land use into account on average it breaks even
the obvious solution would be to use whatever
methods have lower environmental impacts in a
particular situation whether they're organic
or not but organic doesn't allow that it just
limits the options that farmers have based on
this misconception that "natural is better"
in some situations like the cereal
crops and bird biodiversity it's
better to produce the same amount
of food in a smaller area using
conventional farming and leave a strip
of unfarmed land than it is to use a
larger area for organic farming but that
would not be allowed under organic rules
and there are more examples now of
more environmentally sustainable
farming practices that kind of just ignore organic
and we haven't actually dealt with that
mould thing yet natural products tend to
have shorter shelf lives and go off faster
than products with more synthetic components
a lot of synthetic ingredients were originally
designed as improvements on
naturally occurring chemicals
it isn't always the case but there is
a reason why no one is that surprised
where natural products have texture or
color changes or start growing mould
and if you have to throw out half the product
that means that the stuff that you used with
that waste taken into account will be a
lot more resource intensive to produce
speaking of natural things
decomposing our next myth
making synthetic ingredients from
petrochemicals is worse for the environment
there's this idea that synthetic
ingredients made from petroleum are
bad for the environment because
petroleum is a fossil fuel
yes fossil fuels are bad for the environment
extracting petroleum through processes like
fracking can be really destructive and there's
also all the carbon dioxide that gets released
when they're burned as a fuel to release energy
which is the main driver of climate change
but there are some big differences
between petroleum as a fuel and
ingredients that are made from petroleum
Jen: there is no petroleum sourcing with
the intent of making cosmetic ingredients
the petrochemicals that are used are all
waste products from the petroleum sector
societally we want to move away from our
reliance of fossil fuels but until the world
does and while the world is fueled by them the
byproducts that the cosmetics use will be there
in the future this may not be the
case but this is the current reality
Michelle: and making natural
ingredients also uses up fossil fuels
tilling making fertiliser and pesticides moving
water for irrigation harvesting transporting plant
materials processing purification all of this
uses energy which usually comes from fossil fuels
and this time the fossil fuels ARE
purposely dug up and burned as fuels
to get out energy and that burning is the part
that releases carbon dioxide into the atmosphere
if petroleum jelly isn't burnt
then that carbon stays sequestered
in the petroleum jelly and it won't
directly contribute to climate change
again it depends on the specific situation
synthetic isn't always less impactful than natural
making synthetic ingredients processing
and purifying them also uses energy and
again this mostly comes from burning fossil fuels
and again some natural ingredients are
also made from waste materials from
other processes which means energy
savings and less carbon dioxide
so it all comes back to looking
at the data for each individual
ingredient which means life
cycle analyses a few examples
Jen: an LCA from Symrise where they show
that their synthetically produced menthol
produced 8 kilograms of CO2 per kilogram menthol
versus 50 to 100 for its natural counterpart
in contrast we can look to Genomatica's
Brontide butylene glycol where they
halved their CO2 emissions with
the use of plant-based starting
points via biotechnology instead of the
traditional production from fossil fuels
then again since they use a genetically
modified biocatalyst in this process
many consumers and ecocertifiers
still view this as unsustainable
there is no blanket rule about natural always
being more sustainable when we're considering
whether or not natural materials are more or
less impactful we should be asking ourselves
are we using prime agricultural land to
produce them or are they coming from waste
or byproducts from crops that we're
already using anyway in other sectors
Michelle: this also means there's no
blanket rule about what benefits the
fossil fuel industry more buying synthetic
ingredients made from petrochemicals versus
buying natural ingredients that use
a lot of fossil fuels to produce
and speaking of myths about petrochemicals
we need to talk about packaging
the idea that plastic is always worse
for the environment than other types of
packaging is everywhere not just in cosmetics
and it is again a massive oversimplification
like I mentioned before a lot of this
is because we tend to focus on just that
end of life part when we choose products
because we have to personally deal with
it does the bottle go into the bin or can
it be reused or recycled does it degrade
and just like before end of life is
just one part of environmental impact
Jen: if we stop using all plastic and use
more "eco-friendly" alternatives instead like
glass paper and aluminum we would need on
average 3.6 times the material 2.2 times
the energy and there would be an average increase
of about 2.7 times the carbon dioxide emissions
this makes a lot of sense if we look
at each part of the life cycle plastic
isn't universally the worst option for any part
for example with production plastic is
produced via byproducts of the petroleum sector
contrast that to paper where there's a lot of
processing from wood and then glass and aluminum
they can come from recycled sources but there is
a lot of heat involved that increases the impact
Michelle: one of the things we need
to remember is why plastic packaging
became so widespread in the first place it is
really good at protecting the stuff inside it
Jen: to transportation for example
with glass versus plastic plastic is
lightweight for its strength and therefore the
transportation CO2 emissions tend to be less
there's also the matter of glass breakage
And similar for aluminum - aluminum is heavier it
dents easily and people don't want to buy it then
even for end of life mono material
plastic can be recycled about 40 times
and some companies to strive for eco options
are switching to partly paper packaging
which ends up needing a plastic layer since
paper doesn't stand up to for example water
and then as a result they end
up using multi-layered materials
that are harder to recycle and ends up being worse
ultimately here the best packaging option
in terms of the environmental impact is a
case-by-case basis with the best option varying
greatly from individual formulations and users
for example what are the user's habits what kind
of recycling infrastructure do they have available
is your bottle return program
something that they can viably access
blanket statements that plastic equals
bad are both from my perspective
unhelpful and potentially harmful
at the end of the day there is
no silver bullet for sustainable
packaging and every option has its pros and cons
Michelle: so hopefully from all of
this it's clear that sustainability
is complicated and straightforward
blanket rules just don't work
we can't just always choose natural
or organic products or choose glass
over plastic and expect that
we are making the better choice
so what can we actually do to be more sustainable
i think the most obvious thing to do is to just
consume less buying something is almost always
going to be less sustainable than not buying
something regardless of whether it's eco-friendly
Jen: per capita consumerism is the most
environmentally destructive thing we do
societally the overwhelming evidence shows
that the negative impacts associated with
over consumption vastly outweigh any of the
positives associated with "green" innovation
Michelle: so it's important to
consider if you really need to
buy something - because a lot of companies make
it seem like you'll be saving the planet just
by buying their product when in reality it is
probably going to have a net negative impact
and this is filtering into regulation
for example in the uk they've already
said that labels like green sustainable
and eco-friendly could be considered
deceptive unless a business can
prove that as a whole there is a
positive environmental impact to using
the product which is pretty unlikely
Jen: there's a push towards green
consumerism which is ultimately at
odds with sustainability as it paradoxically
increases consumption which increases impact
also there is a market incentivization for green
consumers are willing to pay more for products
they perceive to be green and there is also
a rapidly growing market for impact or
ESG investment where investors want to
invest in companies they again perceive
to be socially or ecologically superior
Michelle: given how how complicated and
context dependent sustainability is I
think it is also really important to ask questions
if a brand says that their product
is sustainable ask them for evidence
because there's so much complexity we can't work
out what's going on without brands
providing some level of transparency
we don't know how the butylene glycol
in their product was made we don't
know whether their production
plant uses renewable energy
Jen: companies pursuing sustainable
development must have access to as
much relevant information as they can in
order to make the best possible decision
to get this information they must measure and
record data in terms of their specific goals
environmental accounting is the
backbone of sustainable development
because you can't be accountable unless
you're actually accounting for things
life cycle assessments can be seen as the most
important tool for understanding a product's
impact for example actually calculating
specific environmental impacts of every
single ingredient and how much is going into the
product or how things are being transported etc
a lot of the time the clean movement just bases
their ideologies on assumptions like
assuming that natural is always safer
if we want to move to reduce our impacts we
need substantiation and we need the specific
measures to be relevant and standardised so you
can actually make comparisons between companies
most of the current popular
"eco" standards certifiers and
the labels you see around don't do this very well
and as a consequence they may actually be
resulting in more greenwashing rather than
true sustainability progress despite
how they're positioning themselves
Michelle: it's also important as consumers to
be informed about what things
are actually more sustainable
the beauty industry responds to
consumer demand if we push for
the wrong thing like non-evidence based
eco-certifications or less plastic or more
natural ingredients regardless of what
the environmental impacts actually are
brands are going to deliver it so we could
be contributing to making everything worse
like we saw with clean beauty people pushing
for paraben-free products meant that brands
started using less effective and more
irritating allergenic preservatives that
led to more skin reactions maybe an allergy
epidemic and products that go off faster
so it's important not to go for easy
answers and make sure you're sharing
the correct information and if you see
people and brands spreading myths it's
important to counteract that and tell people
where they can find better information
Jen: a problem we're increasingly seeing is
misplaced conservation where misinformation
and polarization can actually work
together against sustainable development
for example by leading to a misallocation of
resources into efforts that fundamentally don't
make sense sometimes making the issues
that they're trying to address worse
a second way sustainability misinformation
is working against sustainable development
is via green nudging when ineffective but
perhaps easier policy comes before the
effective but harder policy the effective
policy is less likely to be successful
if the effective policy comes first
the chances of success are much greater
one example here could be carbon
pricing well supported by the
scientific evidence to be an effective
strategy for climate change mitigation
having policy that focuses on things like
carbon footprinting which is widely debated
as an effective strategy come before as
we're currently doing when we finally
get to the carbon pricing it's going
to be an increasingly uphill battle
the order of policy in environmental action in
general matters therefore relying on the best
available evidence is crucially important
as we pursue sustainable development
one final thing I want to add is that
if we want to make significant strides
towards sustainability what we really
need are science-based policy changes
consumer scapegoating and corporate
sustainability aren't working
we've seen this with carbon pricing
which as mentioned is one of the more
well-supported policies for addressing
climate change but instead of focusing
on implementing it effectively there's a lot
of blame on consumers and a lot of focus on
things like carbon footprinting which has
incentivized a pretty problematic market
for carbon offsets which is yet another
whole complex topic I won't get into here
Michelle: sustainability is obviously a huge topic
so we only covered a tiny fraction of it here
let us know what other questions
about sustainability you have
if you want to find out more about
these topics I've linked some of
Jen's posts and podcasts which are
amazing definitely check those out
we've also started Beauty SciComm which
will hopefully spread more accurate
beauty science information check us out as well